you asked me to react to this great
challenge video well let's do it
damn
yeah so the guy is on a crate minding
his own business then this little kid
comes around the guy pleads with him not
to do anything to the crates and the kid
just kicks it right out from under room
that is that is mean so the question is
is this kid liable and the answer is
almost certainly yes you can hold
children liable for negligence you just
have to use the standard of a reasonable
child and if you're talking about
intentional torts the answer is probably
yes too i was actually preparing for my
law school class when i was reminded of
a very famous case called garrett versus
daily that involved an intentional tort
in the daily case a small child takes a
chair away from an adult before they sit
down and they fall and the question was
even if the kid didn't intend for the
fall to happen if there is a substantial
certainty that it will then you're still
liable here this kid seems to know
exactly what he's doing and is almost
certainly guilty of the intentional tort
of battery for kicking out those crates
ouch